[Musique]
hier soir france 2 diffusait le
documentaire noir en france qui donne
donc la parole aux français noirs de
tous âges de tous horizons un
documentaire poignant et en lumière les
témoignages de france et noir victime de
discrimination ils ont baissé mon
pantalon et on dit voilà comment on
déshabille un negro sur le coup j'étais
en pleurs j'ai été très mal quel que
soit leur âge leur origine sociale
qu'ils soient célèbres ou non ils ont
tous été confrontés de loin ou de près
au racisme je vais dans la boutique je
dépose mon cv la meuf déjà regarde hyper
mal quand j'arrive et maintenant on
cherche pas en cherche pas entre
médiation à l'école discrimination au
travail ou injustices quotidiennes ce
documentaire avait pour intention de
bousculer des préjugés encore très
ancrée chez certains quand tu es noir et
en jogging t suspecté directement sur
les réseaux l'émission a suscité de
nombreuses réactions alors extrait choc
dans le documentaire de france 2 noire
en france la france est elle raciste
merci firmine richard de nous avoir
rejoints merci d'être là on est très
content car je vous adore bonjour anne
hommel et
j'adore le look j'adore tout
le salon ouais c'est vrai pas oui on est
très content server achir et j'abandonne
les deux
là alors on va on va revenir sur des
extraits hier de deux documentaires qui
était complètement nous dit franchement
bravo ma banque la banque ou formidable
on va commencer par vous montrer l'un
des extraits du documentaire qui a le
plus tourné sur les raisons on y voit
des enfants choisir entre deux poupées
lui avec une couleur ni le pot au noir
l'autre avec une couleur de peau blanche
si l'on appelle l'expérience de la
poupée mal gardiste cécile helle
poubelles tu préfères
[Musique]
fait
elle celle là
pourquoi parce que ma soeur
elle joue qu'avec ses poupées blanche
quelle est la poupée la moins jolie
[Musique]
la noire parce que j'aime pas trop
pourquoi
c'est ce que tous les enfants de l'école
sont blanches et moi quand je serai
grand je mettrais de lait la crème pour
devenir blanche
terrible famine c'est incroyable de voir
ça oui mais savait d'ailleurs laetitia
et l'eau et qui était à côté de moi a
très bien répondu à cette question s'il
a dit que ses enfants alors ça c'est une
conduite jeu l'expérience qu'on montre
quotidien depuis quelques temps déjà un
des états unis et moi je peux je
comprends en fait je comprends je
n'excuse pas mais je comprends ce qui
s'est passé un peu ce qui se passe dans
la tête de ses enfants l'a d'abord avant
n'y avait pas de poupées noires
attendait comme très récemment qu'on
trouve des poupées noires avant il y en
avait pas moi même j'ai baptisé j'avais
12 ans quand j'ai baptisé une enfant
quand je lui ai offert une poupée
quelques quelques années après sa dette
vous pouvez aussi de grandes qu'elles
vous êtes je lui ai donné une poupée
blanche pour signaler pas de poupée
noire à l'époque les temps ont changé
mais tu on trouve des barbie noire n'y
en avait pas et comme il a bien répondu
laetitia
cela culture on ne te fais pas et mick
quand elle était chez elle au congo et
même aux antilles on ne pouvait pas
aimer votre culture maintenant les
shooteurs plus temps ont changé
heureusement donc forcément 10 à 16 ans
voilà on réagit comme cela mais plus
maintenant alors ya un deuxième extrait
que mon devoir c'est le documentaire on
également sur scandale autour de la
patineuse artistique surya belley la
patineuse française s'était vu
injustement attribué la deuxième place
lors des mondiaux au japon après une
prestation qui méritait pourtant
timeline et regarde une noire qui fait
du patinage artistique verte est
incroyable et vraiment à [ __ ] tout le
monde de patinage artistique elle
faisait partie des meilleurs elle
faisait des sauts périlleux en patins
elle faisait des trucs de ouf mais ce
qui m'avait marqué dans le parcours de
surya bonaly c'était aussi la violence
avec laquelle elle se faisait attaquer
il ne reste plus que la japonaise yuka
sato a passé et sa performance technique
et en dessous de celle de surya bonaly
pourtant les juges ont décidé de
couronner yuka sato
surya bonaly déçu ne garde sa médaille
d'argent que quelques secondes autour du
cou avant de la retirer
c'est l'arrêt des violences
et viol et des décès il n'y a pas
tellement longtemps là bien sûr non mais
oui c'était terrible parce qu'on lui
reprochait son corps c'est à dire ce
qu'elle est on lui reprochait d'être une
gymnaste sur des patins et pas une
patineuse c'était hyper violent et quoi
qu'elle fasse il y avait la mafia des
justes qui la mettait 2e 3e jamais
première parce qu'elle était noire et
parce qu'elle était sûre ya bonaly pour
vous avez répondu oui à la question oui
pour moi être la france est raciste un
bain je réponds avec mon coeur 1,1
million d'actes racistes en 2019 c'est
énorme c'est les + 40 % c'était donc oui
la france est raciste on n'a pas réussi
à éradiquer cette monstruosité arriver
les mentalités changent et l'éducation
des enfants chantent je vois ma fille de
6 ans c'est à dire qu'on nomme pas les
gens avec tel on nomme par le prénom
c'est à dire que pas pour une part une
apparence par une grandeur une taille
une couleur mais je crois que ça aussi
ça une éducation mes vidéos la parole
est libérée et mettant les gens le brise
vraiment je suis raciste il faut
admettre que tenir la six mois que la
majorité des français sont racistes
monde vous dit et enracinement fois
c'est des relations qui ne disait pas
son nom il est clair que ce que dit
vraiment mais mes firme est ce que je
ferai dans ce documentaire comme c'est
par exemple dans le cadre surya bonaly
hermine soit très bien que lui
reprochait de ne pas très gracieux dans
la danse à aucun moment enfin acquis qui
a dit à un moment que c'était sa couleur
est gracieuse parce que sous-entendu son
corps noir n'était pas assurée je
n'avais jamais entendu ça parce que dans
l'imaginaire rassure nos qui le disaient
voilà exactement mais dans la sueur de
s'affirmer pas d'espoir c'est un racisme
quand on subit subtilement les choses
comme ça c'est du racisme qui ne disait
pas son nom mais maintenant les gens lui
disent oui mais pas les juges c'est ça
qui m'a ainsi permis aux dogues c'est
qu' aucun juge de dire après coup je
reconnais qu'elle aurait dû gagner donc
c'est un racisme peut être aussi à
l'envers de dire est ce qu'on n'est pas
en train de dire que c'est un racisme
alors qu'elle était jusqu'à ce que deux
mérité bien du racisme mais je ne peux
pas dire jamais je ne pourrais dire que
ce pays est raciste ou qu'il dira si
jordan
le racisme est un racisme en fois celle
annoncée voilà en italie bien sûr mais
la france
marine le pen en autriche signé oui bon
d'accord c'est que tous les gens qui
suivent marine le pen soit raciste il y
en a beaucoup qui le disent oui mais
c'est pas toujours y accepte les thèses
de marine le pen oui mais sont pas tous
racistes
alors on va voir maintenant des
problèmes dénoncés par les personnes qui
témoignait dans le documentaire aussi
alors ça ça a dérangé c'est aussi le
rapport avec la police et plus
précisément toutes les fois ils seront
arrêtés regardez le témoignage de
soprano
appel avec mon groupe les psy4 de la
rime en prend le train pour année un
concert et qu'elle est en première
classe et qu on connait tous tranquilles
et que tu vois le contrôleur qui
arrivent là même pas commencé qu idy la
deuxième classe et là bas et qui voit
que notre manager et blain et qui nous
dit il parle français eux toi tu es là
tu le regardes tu le penses que tu poses
des questions tu le vois qu'il devient
tout rouge que la police a été appelée
avant même de contrôler tous nos
papilles et nous truc tout simplement
parce qu'il nous a vus et par contre ils
ne parlaient pas avec nous en parler
qu'avec notre manager blanc la police
qui nous attend qu'on descend alors
qu'on a vu nos billes comporter faire
des concerts d'un matériau siggil
highway quand même quand même c'est
parti jusque là on n'a même pas dit un
mot c'est parti trop loin d'autres sopra
que j'embrasse d'ailleurs qui est
formidable oui moi j'ai trouvé le
documentaire absolument incroyable très
édifiant mais en même temps je suis un
peu d'accord avec mathieu c'est à dire
que je pense que la france n'est pas
raciste
par essence enfin moi je me méfie quand
on essentialiser quand on globalise
alors oui à des racistes oui à la
discrimination oui à du contrôle au
faciès oui à la violence policière parce
que vous êtes noir parce que vous êtes
haram et donc c'est insupportable il
faut la combattre il faut pas
essentialiser il faut pas globaliser non
sinon on s'en sortira pas c'est parce
qu'en fait on est en train de toucher
d'accord oui là je vous avais dit ouah
toutes les églises avaient donné faut
pas légalisée aux élections voilà oui
mais à part ça le documentaire était
formidable et et après qu'est ce que je
vais y aller il y avait un hic noah
williams nico noir est d'ailleurs lundi
que noah et a été pas mal j'ai dénoncé
quid des fonctionnaires mais justement
posé
voir va voir l'extrait l'une des
personnalités françaises invitées à
témoigner aussi sur le documentaire
c'est yannick noah quel premier français
moi avoir gagné roland garros
écoutez bien ce qu'ils racontent son
témoignage a beaucoup fait parler et il
s'est fait fracasser yannick noah
regarde s'était pas que jouer un rôle
mais c'est que j'avais un vrai rôle
c'est que je représentais pas juste
yannick je représente aussi
tous les blacks qui jouaient au tennis
c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai
demandée ça m'est tombé dessus voilà
j'avais envie de montrer que c'était que
j'allais être le premier à le faire et à
prouver que le client arrive à gagner
que c'était quelque chose qui nous
donnait la force dans certains ça peut
être une pression mais ça devienne la
farce
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui alors vous voulez poser une question
à lui parce qu'en fait on lui reproche
d'avoir utilisé la terminologie blacks
oui et d'ailleurs en lui ont reproché
d'avoir fait saga africa d avoir
finalement à ce pas lui qui chantait
saga africaine danse dans la mousse
pieds nus devant tous les blancs
lui-même a contribué à tous et ishi
racistes
alors c'est ridicule le monde et la
désactivation de mots qui n'accepte ni
de côté ou de l'autre que ce soit du
blanc du noir moi je suis une noire une
belle femme de couleur quelques couleurs
alors tu vas différentes couleurs du
black nos noah ok tu te mau qui conjugue
la bouche de certaines personnes et je
suppose je leur demande pourquoi unique
nous annuel croît lui disait qu'il ai
dit effectivement mais même de son côté
je dis non d'accord n'a pas le dire oui
aux quotas mieux américain n'en sais
rien mais peut-être que pourquoi c'est
un mot que moi je jouis fut aussi donc
on l'a lu qu'on lui reproche de levier
je peux comprendre nouveau procès de la
voir chanter sa gaffe car le gars il est
d'origine africaine sa saga fukasawa qui
est selon lui sa partie de sa culture on
la lui reproche